thanks to surfshark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
your body is a finely tuned machine
honed by untold generations of evolution
to be perfectly adapted to survival in
the environment here on earth
or at least that's what you've been led
to believe
the reality is rather different
it's easy to think that evolution by
natural selection given enough time
should produce perfection
but is your body really all that perfect
i'm not talking about bingo wings or
beer bellies here
lockdown's taking its toll on all of us
i mean that you watching this video have
body parts that
to put it mildly
make no sense
whatsoever
don't believe me
according to youtube about 85 percent of
the people watching this video will be
human males
if you happen to be one of them let me
ask you a question
how much use have you gotten out of your
nipples in the last couple of years
i'm going to go ahead and guess not a
lot well not unless you happen to be
into some fairly niche fetishes anyway
belly buttons are another example
they don't do anything they're just
vaguely disgusting lint repositories
and this rabbit hole goes a lot deeper
than nipples and navels
men have nipples because we were all
female in the earliest stages of
development in the womb and our belly
buttons are essentially our first scars
marking the site where our umbilical
cords once plugged us into our mothers
like weird fleshy petrol pumps
these useless body bits are
developmental byproducts that exist
thanks to the way we human beings are
made
but not all of our pointless parts can
be explained away by how we came into
the world
some known as vestigial structures are
evolutionary leftovers that tell us
really interesting things about the
weird and wonderful creatures we used to
be
long before we were human
vestigial structures are adaptations
that were once beneficial to our
ancestors but no longer serve their
original purpose in humans
and often serve no purpose whatsoever
that might sound a bit abstract so let
me give you an example now if you love
travelling like i do then you'll love
the fastest and easiest vpn surf shot
did you know surf shock also helps you
to avoid price discrimination based on
your location so you can actually save
money on plane tickets and car rentals
whilst travelling
surfshark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch of your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support by using surfsharkvpn
you can stay anonymous and secure online
personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk
it's really easy all i have to do is
switch over my location settings and
there i have it access to all my
favorite programs
surf shark maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3200 servers
in over 65 countries runs completely on
ram so they can't log your data even if
they wanted to by using the code 42 you
will benefit from an 83 discount plus
free extra months for free
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below
don't miss out
as you've probably noticed you don't
have whiskers unless you're into yet
another niche fetish
you might also have noticed that almost
all other mammals do
whiskers are basically hands for your
face
in most animals they're there to feel
the world in order to help them with
navigation particularly at night when
the eyes alone can't be relied upon
despite the fact humans have never had
whiskers about a third of you watching
this video will have muscles in your
upper lips whose sole purpose it is to
allow you to consciously manipulate the
whiskers
that you don't have
in humans these vibrasal capsular
muscles as they're known are essentially
an evolutionary relic an invisible
reminder that somewhere in the distant
past long before modern humans existed
one of our ancestors had whiskers and
the ghost of that long-lost evolutionary
adaptation still lurks in our dna
in case you're wondering i'm fairly sure
i don't have vibrissal capsular muscles
because i've spent all morning trying to
navigate using my mustache and got
absolutely nowhere
i had to give up after almost getting
run over on the m62
the bristle capsule muscles aren't the
only useless muscles in our bodies in
fact there are examples pretty much
everywhere in your torso arms legs even
in your head
try and wiggle your ears
does anything happen
most likely not
which is odd because our ears come
pre-packaged with a set of free muscles
designed to move them around
lots of other mammals use those muscles
to physically point their ears towards
unfamiliar sounds allowing them to
better pinpoint the approach of
potential threats
in humans they hardly function at all
we make up for our lack of ear
flexibility by having a good range of
movement in our necks along the
horizontal plane something many animals
with mobile ears like dogs cats and
horses don't have
but our bodies still go to the trouble
of growing those useless muscles
regardless interestingly about one in
five people are actually able to use
their ear muscles to do an admittedly
fairly pathetic amount of ear wiggling
but there's no appreciable benefit to it
it's just another nod to our
evolutionary past
even more interestingly not only do we
have vestigial ear muscles that don't do
anything
we also have a load of normal circuitry
to go along with them a 2015 study found
that when humans hear an unexpected
noise our ear muscles activate in a
futile attempt to orient our ears
towards the sound
it's thought that these muscles and the
normal circuits that support them have
been vestigial in humans and our
ancestors for around 25 million years
vestigial traits and structures aren't
just limited to obscure muscle groups
take your wisdom teeth for example
have you ever wondered why we gain an
extra set of teeth as teenagers that
serve no purpose other than to get stuck
cause infections and generally wreak
havoc in our mouths it isn't as though
most of us have any trouble chewing our
food before they come along
our ancestors on the other hand did have
trouble chewing their food
early man had a diet that was rather
more demanding on the teeth than what
we're used to today including large
amounts of nuts seeds and tough gamey
meat
as a result wear and tear on the teeth
was significant
a lack of functioning gnashers could be
life threatening to early man so we
evolved a third set of molars to share
the load
but over the last 12 000 years or so two
things have happened
our diets have changed and the human jaw
has steadily shrunk
these days wisdom teeth are kind of a
liability
so much so that some scientists believe
evolution is slowly doing away with them
altogether
some populations like indigenous
mexicans have already lost them
by the way if you've ever fallen on your
ass at just a right angle you'll be well
acquainted with your coccyx it's the
part that was burning in agony your
coccyx is basically the bit right at the
base of your spine where your tail used
to attach and in this case i don't mean
that in some distant evolutionary sense
you watching this video
used to have a tail
all mammals have a tail-like structure
during their development in utero in
humans it's mostly prominent in embryos
that are around a month old
disappearing about four weeks later
at least that's what usually happens
in incredibly rare cases
the tail never goes away and has to be
surgically removed once the baby's born
unlike wisdom teeth we're unlikely to
lose our coccyxies
there's a word
whilst some human vestigial structures
no longer have any function whatsoever
our stubby little internal tales still
play an active role in our bodies acting
as an anchor point for nearby tendons
ligaments and muscles
one human vestigial trait you'll
probably have seen every time you look
in the mirror without ever really
noticing it it's that strange little
membrane in the corner of your eye
it's called the plica semilunaris
and whilst it does still have a use in
humans it helps both to give your
eyeballs greater range of movement and
in the drainage of tears
it's really just the last fleshy remnant
of a nictating membrane that vaguely
disturbing third eyelid found in many
birds reptiles and a few mammals that
provide protection and keeps the
eyeballs moist without the need to blink
and momentarily lose vision again humans
have never had one but our ancestors did
and it's never quite gone away
as strange as it is to discover our
bodies are riddled with these odd
vestigial structures evolutionary
fossils that once you notice them seem
suddenly so out of place
we actually exhibit several vestigial
behaviors too
and if anything
they're even weirder
take goosebumps those little lumps are
spread over your skin when you're scared
or feeling strong emotions
have you ever wondered why we get them
the answer is of course
for absolutely no reason whatsoever
goosebumps are formed when the erector
pili muscles tiny muscles that attach
the base of each hair follicle contract
causing our body hair to stand on end
in animals with thick fur or feathers
this does two things in the cold it
traps a layer of air close to the skin
which helps to keep the animal warm
or if the animal feels threatened the
resulting puffed up hairstyle
fur style makes the animal look larger
than it really is warding off potential
predators
since we humans have lost most of the
thick body hair most of our ancestors
supported goosebumps don't actually
cause a significant warming effect for
us
and whilst i do know a few impressively
hairy people they don't suddenly look
noticeably bigger or more imposing when
they get scared whilst goosebumps don't
do anything beneficial for humans they
don't really come with much of a
downside either so there's never really
been enough evolutionary pressure for
them to disappear and they've just stuck
around
doing bugger all for countless
generations the palmer grasp reflex is
another example of vestigial behavior
you know that adorable thing babies do
when they grab your finger as though
their life depended on it in the case of
human babies that reflex is pointless
but for some of our ancestors whose
young would have clung to their mother's
fur as modern primates do their lives
really did depend on it despite the fact
the palmer grasp reflex is vestigial in
humans and serves no benefit beyond
being undeniably cute it remains
remarkably strong
some newborn babies are able to support
their entire body weight whilst hanging
by just their fingers something that
can't be said for plenty of adults okay
okay i think it's about time we talked
about the exploding elephant in the room
here
the appendix you've probably been
watching this video waiting for me to
mention this treacherous little organ
perhaps the most famous vestigial
structure in the entire human body the
thing is it turns out it may not be so
vestigial after all
while scientists have long theorized
that the appendix is a useless organ
whose only aspiration in life is to act
like a tiny terrorist and blow itself up
when we least expect it
recent research suggests it may have an
important use after all
acting as a reservoir for beneficial gut
bacteria
if you've ever had the shits
like the proper shots
you'll know what it's like to feel as
though you've emptied the entire
contents of your body into the toilet
bowl
it's forged that after such a
shall we say
clear out the appendix is able to
replenish your gut supply of good
bacteria
think of it like a little bottle of
yakult with a really bad temper
whilst we're on the subject of vestigial
structures that might not be so
vestigial after all i should probably
point out that like the appendix science
may eventually prove that some of the
other vestigial structures i've
mentioned in this video have uses we
aren't currently aware of the human body
is incredibly complex and it isn't
always easy to be completely sure
exactly what does what
hence why the appendix was able to sneak
under the radar for so long speaking of
things being incredibly complex some
people believe that humans and all other
animals for that matter
are too elaborate to have been shaped by
evolution alone
and that only an intelligent designer
also known by his nickname god
could have created such mind-bogglingly
complicated creatures vestigial
structures and behaviors however throw a
giant coccyx shaped spanner in the works
of this theory which is sometimes known
as intelligent design
think about it if we really were
designed by a higher power
why did he she or it
bother giving us all these odd little
adaptations that don't do anything for
us
but do do something in other animals
so far as i can tell there are only
really two answers to that question
either we weren't designed from scratch
and instead evolved from other creatures
over millions of years
or whoever it is that made us
did so in such a way that was
deliberately designed to trick us into
thinking we evolved from other creatures
and if that's the case it's kind of hard
to see what the motive might have been
there
now don't get me wrong i'm not trying to
say that vestigial traits are an
argument that there isn't a god
that's a different question altogether
they're just compelling evidence for
evolution and therefore against any
theories that deny evolution
young earth creationism for example
whatever your beliefs
there isn't necessarily any reason why
some form of creator
can't co-exist with the theory of
evolution that's not an argument i'm
trying to make by the way it's just
interesting to think about anyway the
next time you're down the gym and
someone tells you that his body is a
temple
you might want to politely point out to
him that in reality his body is actually
a graveyard of evolutionary detritus
that's full of random bits and pieces
that don't really do anything
that should wipe the smug look of his
face
thanks for watching